It's hard being a reporter.
But if it were easy, everyone
would want to do it, right?
Right.
♪♪
-Afternoon, comrades.
-Who are you guys?
-The vigilantes for truth?
-We're very entrepreneurial.
GIRL: I'm in high school now,
okay? Things are gonna be
different.
I don't want them
to be different.
You have to start doing
some normal kid stuff.
Oh, my God.
Are those dead?
GIRL: I thought I'd already
written the most important
story of my life,
but this was bigger.
This town, there are all sorts
of rules you gotta play by.
GIRL: I think something in the
harbor is making people sick.
And they'd been covering
this up for years.
♪ Messages keep getting clearer ♪
Oh, my God.
♪ And I ain't got nothing to say ♪
GIRL: If we don't figure out
what they're covering up,
everyone in this town
could be in danger.
We're not gonna let that happen.
Seriously, you're like some
old person inside my house.
♪ There's something happening somewhere ♪
GIRL: This could be
how we find Richie.
He saw something,
and that's why he got taken.
♪♪ (continues)
WOMAN: Criminal trespassing--
-(dogs barking)
-...on a school night.
But in a purposeful way...
for a good cause?
♪ You can't start a fire ♪
You need to get control
of your daughter.
♪ Can't start a fire without... ♪
Is that supposed to be
some kind of a threat?
♪ This gun's for hire ♪
You have no idea what
these people are capable of.
The hardest stories
to cover are the ones
you care most about.
♪♪
We're young,
but we are not stupid!
I'm not afraid of you!
They cannot stop her
from speaking the truth!
♪ Just dancing in the dark ♪